12 years after Grace and Chance's
breakout moment on The Ellen Degeneres
Show he's calling out the TV host for
being a quote manipulative person I
stand behind all of it you know I've
been wanting to tell this story now for
multiple years and was repeatedly told
not to the now 25 year old dropped
in his wrong
his role profile reflecting on his life
and career after this viral video of him
performing Lady Gaga's Paparazzi at
school
do you love me
[Music]
landed him on the popular talk show at
age 12. it's crazy how many hits this
has now right it's just it's it's it's
amazing grace and says of that moment
quote we were so unsure of what we were
getting into and the person that helped
Cure All That skepticism and chaotic
energy was Ellen he claims when they met
she told him quote I'm going to protect
you I'm going to be here for you we're
going to do this together I love what I
do I love making people happy and I love
seeing people laugh and have a good time
but Grayson says once he signed on to
her record company Ellen became quote
domineering and way too quote
controlling claiming she wanted him to
emulate Justin Bieber and that behavior
came to light when she allegedly gave
him a screener of Bieber's Never Say
Never documentary
Grayson says he didn't immediately watch
it and claims Ellen called his mother
and berated her for it and once his
album and ticket sales dropped he also
alleges the comedian completely quote
removed and abandoned herself from him
but despite their Fallout Grayson
continued to appear on Ellen over the
years
[Music]
he recalls during that 2019 appearance
Ellen praised Grayson for coming out as
gay two years prior on her show I really
wanted to make sure that it didn't seem
like I was trying to profit or you know
sort of promote my sexuality as a means
of getting more Fame and popularity and
so I just um I waited I waited until I
felt confident and yeah posted up an
Instagram message and felt like that was
the right thing to do yeah it was
beautiful I read it it was really
beautiful and I think we all were so
happy to to see that you were happy but
to Grayson the moment felt quote cheap
quote she had nothing to do with that
when I came out I hadn't spoken to her
in years that's so messed up that you're
now showing the world as if we're so
tight we're so good and behind the
scenes you are this insanely
manipulative person
ET has reached out to Ellen for comment
the truth is is what you saw on TV and
and what was sort of pitched out you
know to the mainstream just wasn't what
was happening behind the scenes yeah
Grayson dropped his Tick Tock doubling
down on all his claims I think
now that I'm 25 and I'm older I can
recognize that what happened to me as a
kid was
not cool it was not okay and I'm sure
people will have a lot to say about the
article and how I maybe appear
ungrateful for her efforts in the
beginning and the truth is is that I am
grateful for her giving me a start but
I'm more grateful to myself for the
moments when I got dropped and
everything went awry when I was a kid
I'm thankful to 15 year old me that
picked up the pieces and kept on going
and kept on fighting
[Music]